here's another big controversy an
important controversy it deals with a
Timeless question one that has perplexed
humans for Millennia and the question is
this
should you crack an egg on your child's
head is that a good parenting strategy
or a poor one
it's an interesting question here's the
Daily Mail parents were today facing a
furious backlash over a new tick tock
challenge that sees them cracking eggs
on their children's heads footage shows
toddlers left confused in pain or
bursting into tears after the egg crack
challenge which some have compared to
child abuse
so these videos from Tick Tock are going
viral and people have lots of opinions
mostly their opinions are this is very
bad this is abusive lots of people very
upset about this we have a here's here's
one video that I saw pop up on Twitter
and this one got tens of millions of
views uh again most of the reaction has
been extremely negative people are very
upset about this but here's what the egg
crack challenge looks like watch
that hurts
I wanted to crack it
go crack it
whoo
that hurts are you okay
ready yeah
how long has this gone it's like a 25
minute video of parents cracking eggs on
their kid's head this is what you get on
Tick Tock now okay let me I'll give the
official verdict on this situation
um a lot of the reaction on the internet
has been overwrought as you might expect
from the internet this is not physical
abuse okay you're not going to give a
kid a concussion with an egg uh no one's
going to go to the hospital with a skull
fracture because because they had an an
egg on their head should you do this to
your kid though well the problem is that
is that most of these kids are too young
um a young child isn't going to
understand he's not going to get the
joke and uh will just be disturbed and
confused by it and start crying and you
don't want to make your kid cry it's not
fun or funny and which is exactly what
you see in these videos
which is why I would never do this to my
three-year-old daughter like she would
she would lose her mind okay now my
ten-year-old son or my six-year-old son
on the other hand they would they would
laugh they would be the funniest thing
that ever happened to them they wouldn't
they they would tell everyone it'd be
hilarious for them uh the only problem
is that then they would start doing like
if I do that to my 10 year old son he
would laugh hysterically and then take
out an egg and do it to himself
uh and then there'd just be egg all over
the place
so that's the age of the child matters
the temperament of the child matters and
you have to take these things into
consideration also the Rapport you have
with your child if you aren't the kind
of parent who horses around with your
kids normally and plays pranks on them
but then you do this out of nowhere for
tick tock uh they're gonna be totally
confused and weirded out that's the
other thing you see in this video is
like you know these kids they're not
used to
um their their mothers you know playing
around with them like this and so
they're like what are you doing
understandably so
and that's really the point here okay
doing this for tick tock that's the
point that's the problem that's what I
have an issue with if you just came to
me and told me that the other day you
were making scrambled eggs with your kid
and you just kind of like there was you
weren't filming it but you just
spontaneously cracked the egg on the
kid's head because you thought it'd be
funny and you thought they'd get a kick
out of it uh but then they didn't and
they started crying and you felt bad if
you just told me about that I wouldn't I
wouldn't say oh this you're an abuser
I'm calling CPS
no I think you know what I think I'd
think oh well you're you're spending
time with your kid you're making
breakfast uh you're including them and
then you're horsing around you're being
spontaneous uh sounds to me like you're
a good parent okay you went a little
overboard with it with the egg thing you
thought they'd find it funny they didn't
it happens no big deal
uh but when you do it for tick tock it's
not spontaneous it's you're not just
having fun with your kid
um
you are harvesting your child for social
media engagement and that is the problem
when it comes to carrying your valuables
or self-defense items in your vehicle
most people feel they have to choose
between safety and convenience so I'm
breaking in your car will typically
check the glove box under the seats
under the center console well now we can
outsmart them with the head rest safe
which gives you convenience and peace of
mind the header is safe is exactly what
it sounds like you can replace your
standard headrest in your car with easy
to access safe uh to access the safe you
just pull the side part off and you can
either use your fingerprint use a key or
manually type in the code to open the
safe it's your choice there's no way
that anyone would know that your
headrest safe is even there and even if
they did there's no way they could get
it open without using one of the three
methods to unlock it headrest save is a
universal design that allows it to fit
all vehicles and the best part is these
come in a variety of colors to make the
to match the interior of your car as
well I have their black leather Vulcan
headrest for my vehicle and I love it
took my family out to dinner last week
and the restaurant only had valet
parking I thanks to my headrest save I
was able to leave valuables in the car
and kept them safe without any worry at
all depending on the day I'll put
self-defense items cash medications in
the safe gives them Peace of Mind
knowing that it will stay out of the
hands of our kids The valets Intruders
anyone so what are you waiting for save
a hundred dollars today at the
headrestsafe.com with promo code wall
should check out that's the
headrestsave.com promo code Walsh
that's the issue I have with all these
different you know every week it's
another prank that that parents are
playing on their kids
and usually what happens is that you
know the videos you see the kid reacts
in a negative way and they don't think
it's funny
and then people respond by saying like
the prank itself is this terrible
horrible thing and maybe sometimes there
are different pranks I I can't think of
all them but
um
that's not usually the issue it's like
if you want to joke around with your kid
that's fine
but the problem is that you're you're
not doing this
because you're trying to have fun with
your kid or you're just a fun funny
parent who's joking around
you're doing it because you're doing it
for the audience out there
okay you're taking this moment that
should just be like it's like first of
all why
you're making scrambled eggs that's a
great thing
to do
but at what point do you think I got to
get my phone out and film doing this
you know every Saturday morning I make
scrambled eggs whether it's like it's a
family tradition I'll make a breakfast
I I never think to take my phone out and
my kids will always come in they want to
crack an egg they want to do whatever
they want to flip they want to scramble
the eggs they want to flip the bacon
they want to do different things I never
think to myself I got to get this on I
gotta film this
because it's not for an audience it's
just it's just a moment in your family
let it be that everyone doesn't need to
see it
and so that's the issue
when you make it into a spectacle for
the public that's when it becomes a
problem and that's the problem with all
these different kinds of videos
but also yes whether you're whether
you're running the camera or not
uh don't hit your three-year-old over
the head with an egg it's like that's
not they're not going to find a phone
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there